often often often kids
when they are being introduced to Mom or
Dad's new boyfriend or girlfriend
they feel a sense of disloyalty to their
birth parents on the other side
as though if I accept dad's new
girlfriend
I'm betraying mom
and
if you and your ex were able to sit down
and be super transparent with one
another probably in a way that if you
hadn't been it would have saved your
marriage originally and say you're gonna
date again I'm gonna date again we have
to be in communication because your wife
may bring home some scumbag that you
don't want around your kids that's
number one and vice versa and number two
you need your your ex to say to your
kids and they come home and say dad's
got a girlfriend that her first words
are I'm so glad dad's happy